uh in alphabetical order uh kemi
vadernock proposed by lee rowley
seconded by julia lopez
serena braverman proposed by david jones
seconded by miriam cates
jeremy hunt
proposed by esther mcveigh and seconded
by anthony mangle
penny mordant
proposed by andrea ledson dave andrea
ledson and seconded by craig tracy
rishi sunak
proposed by dominic rabb
seconded by mel stride
liz truss
proposed by simon clark
seconded by therese coffey
tom tougandat proposed by ann marie
trevelyan
seconded by james daley
and nadim zahawi proposed by brandon
lewis seconded by amanda milling those
eight will go to the first round
ballot tomorrow between 1 30 and 3 30
with the results announced
as soon as we can
after that thank you
well short and sweet there from the
chairman of the 1922 committee there and
simply telling us those that will
proceed as you heard so graham say there
to the ballot of mps tomorrow
all he
mentioned there was the proposers and
seconders and then that they have got at
least 18 other mps to support them the
actual numbers we do not know although
i'm sure we will fairly soon because
this is going to be a fairly leaky
leadership campaign let's go back to our
political editor beth rigby on that and
then there were eights well there there
were nine about 15 minutes ago but uh
sajid javid withdrew voluntarily
yeah and looking at that list uh but it
might be that three i i could see three
of them that potentially just do not get
uh the numbers tomorrow to proceed uh to
the next round perhaps even four of them
we do know that mordent
uh
sunak and truss are the ones uh kind of
uh in the lead and then tom tuggenheart
of course who is the uh the favored
candidate of the liberal group within
the party the one uh nation
conservatives uh but look this is going
to get whittled down very quickly we've
got a ballot tomorrow and the first
result
if you don't get 30 votes or more you're
out and then there could be another
ballot the next day we could get to the
final two as early as monday next week
depending on how
it all shakes out but i really think
that now there's going to be quite a
big fight on the hand
between penny morden and liz trust to
try and get into that final two with
rishi sunak
who looks at the moment pretty nailed on
as the clear front runner with mps